are we going to record on this
hi and welcome I am Jenna and I'm a 32
year old virgin I am excited to answer
your questions and talk about my
experience so Who am I I'm a storyteller
and a performer in New York and my
journey with virginity is an interesting
one and an individual one right because
they all are and so tonight we're gonna
get into your questions and sort of the
definitions of virginity and sex and all
that stuff when did I first learn about
sex is the question I can't really
remember I I think I watched an animated
film that I think was about puberty and
that was maybe when I was like eight or
seven or eight and I just remember at
one point there was a pool and there was
an egg that swam into it and then there
was like shark and a shark you know
always like doing it and and the egg
jumps out of the pool and the shark
jumps out of the pool and it's actually
a sperm and a top hat and they dance and
like the eggs in a wedding dress so
exactly like how it happens in real life
and that was probably like the first
kind of sex ed and I think my mom got
that video out of the library and she
also made us watch the video of my birth
which is a real trait on how to heard
about that stuff
when did your friends start having sex
my friends started having sex I think
some people had sex in high school I was
kind of a floater so friend is like an
interesting term but my closest friend
in high school didn't have sex
he's a wonderful gay guy and so kind of
virginity in sex in terms of like
homosexuality and that sort of stuff is
interesting because he was having
certain types of sex but yeah high
school some people were doing it Deana
Hernandez Dianna Hernandez oh my god hi
hi Dianna how do you deal with the
social pressures in regards to having
sex I'm also a virgin hello
I think it's I'm 32 now and it's gotten
to a point where I kind of don't care
but I how did I deal with the pressure I
took it day by day and I navigated it
well sometimes and really badly at other
times I think when you're a virgin you
can choose to use it as something that
you see as a point of pride or see is
this thing that's bad or hopefully and I
think this might in my opinion is like
the the most healthy to think about it
is like it's just another thing I
bleached blonde hair I'm a virgin
I'm 32 took another fact about me it
doesn't really define me which is a lot
easier said than done depending on your
level of self-esteem and as you said
social pressure which is very real did
you want to have sex as a teenager yes
don't all teenagers gonna have sex maybe
not but especially then when you're so
you're so hormonal you're like a little
horny monster and yeah I definitely
wanted to have sex as a teenager I
didn't want to have sex with any of the
people in my high school so that was
sort of easy in a way because it wasn't
like I was pining after a certain person
but yeah I wanted connection I think we
all do
yeah did you ever come close to having
sex yes but only like sort of recently
this past summer and so the tail end of
my 31st year yes I came close to having
sex but also how are we defining sex
because like I've had some types of sex
so yeah yes so you guys are live
chatting your questions so if I'm
reading your name at that out that's
from the live chat and then there's
questions from buzzfeed community
basically whatever you ask I'm gonna try
to answer as best I can and I can't wait
to connect with you and also thank you
for asking and for being here yeah I
came close to having sex but he didn't
have a condom thank God because I didn't
want to have sex with him what did you
imagine sex would be like when you were
younger well I grew up on romance novels
so I think I thought it
is very much like that which is not real
it's like the Vaseline on the lens
version of having sex so in typically in
romance novels their heteronormative the
guy makes the other guy makes the woman
have an orgasm first then they have sex
no one isn't in pain everything works
out and so it's um
it's not really real but that's what I
thought that it would look like I might
not be pronouncing this right but you go
to Lou asks do you watch porn yes i
watch porn porn is great if you don't
want to watch it don't watch it if you
want to watch it great but I'll just say
this is a caveat if you're watching porn
as a virgin and I say this having never
had sex but like that's not how sex is
maybe sometimes it is but baby you know
just looks like I'll be aware of what
we're watching right and that it's like
entertainment are you religious
I was I was raised religious a little
bit yeah so that helped with being
essentially repressed and now I would
think that I'm kind of more spiritual
than religious so I kind of only pray
when like the train is later I dropped
something so but it's interesting how
religion and you know virginity are so
closely tied and that's something to
think about too right Mackenzie Pisano's
rights have you ever wanted to have sex
with someone and why didn't you did you
get scared to have sex
have you ever sexted great questions
thank you so much yes I have wanted to
have sex with someone and why didn't I
fear fear can make you do a lot of
things it can also make you do nothing
at all it can kind of stunt you and that
was the case for me do did you ever get
scared to have sex yes as I was just
talking about fear I think that fear is
sort of the driving force now as to why
I'm not or Hawaii I wasn't having sex
and have I ever sexted yes I sexting is
kind of fun it's like a game although
it's not and it feels like a fake
intimacy and I go back and forth with
sexting if you and the person you're
sexting
know what it is which is that it's fake
and I mean just like words pictures are
a whole other thing be careful with
pictures do what you're comfortable with
but yeah
sexting is a slippery slope but yes I
have done it all right am i waiting for
marriage no I was initially waiting for
marriage but now I'm not I don't know if
I'll get married so how do I deal with
the social pressures regarded in regards
having sex I'm also a virgin hello
fellow virgins yeah I mean it's it's
tough I think I've gone back and forth
with this I think it was a lot I was a
lot harder on myself when I was younger
and now as I get older there's more
stuff that comes up there's more
sometimes like it feels like more
important stuff in your life and so it
just kind of gets pushed down on the
list of like there's other pressures
like I got to pay my rent
I'm am I gonna sleep with someone and
they're gonna pay my rent like then the
two aren't connected then I got to pay
my rent I got to make my bills so that
stuff sort of takes precedent so the the
pressure of having sex what do you think
of the word prude I think the word
itself is fine I think how we use it is
what matters right but I definitely was
a prude I was just really scared really
scared to do anything and that's okay
because for some of my life being scared
that that scarcity kept me sort of safe
so prude I think is a fine word I just
think you have to be careful how you're
telling you know using it when did you
first recognize you were the only person
in your group of friends that was still
a virgin oh you know when you're
swapping stories and someone's like well
you know when you're having sex and
you're like yeah no no I definitely know
what you mean
yeah it just it it comes up when you're
trying to get to know someone and
connecting with things where people
might ask you advice or people will be
talking about a bad or good experience
and it'll kind of be that thing of well
you know I don't know cuz I've never
done it and then sometimes it's silence
and then sometimes it's rapid-fire
questions kind of like right now um so
yeah when did I recognize it though
college I think I yeah
college is kind of when I really made
college maybe is when I realized oh not
everyone's engine still so for me yeah
like 20 but yeah I mean it's also it's
interesting to be the only virgin in the
group cuz I also I'm a virgin who needs
a lot of information too so I've always
wanted to be well-informed and I've
always been curious and interested in
sex so I wanted to learn everything I
could about sex and STDs and pregnancy
and all this stuff so sometimes my
friends that were sexually active we're
actually asking me advice or things to
know maybe because it was scarier for
them to look up information about SGI's
but I could do it you know from the
privacy of my little virgin laptop and
I'd be fine with it
I don't know uh what were you afraid of
I think I was afraid of someone seeing
my body of someone seeing me if we want
to get real deep because there's an
intimacy that you can't really run away
from when you're literally naked but
you're it's a very like emotionally
naked experience right so I was afraid
of someone seeing me and what that would
mean and for me personally in my life if
we want to dig deeper into that fear
it's a lot about like I was afraid to
enjoy myself and have fun and that stems
from sort of restricting myself from
having the most joyful kind of life so
that gets into other deep stuff
but yeah that's what I was afraid of I
was afraid of kind of you know living
twister x elite have you ever touched
yourself yes yeah I think it's important
I don't think you have to I want you to
do whatever is comfortable
I didn't masturbate until college and I
was it was only because I was like in a
summer
grammar at a single dorm I think it was
after watching Sex in the City I did not
do it right the first time because it's
not gonna mean maybe it'll feel great
the first time you touch yourself but I
didn't know what I was doing but it's
great that it was my own body so I had
time to explore and figure it out and
find what I liked and yeah so I think
it's important to touch yourself virgin
or not you know just feel around you
know can't hurt it can't hurt if it's
you right I mean it couldn't hurt just
be careful
be gentle at first go slow
maze world writes do you get made fun of
for being a virgin how do you deal with
that I did get made fun of yeah I got a
lot of like what are you waiting for you
know just go have sex with someone just
whatever some more vulgar comments about
like what it must look like down there
things like that which is like I'm so
glad everyone has an opinion about my
body right how did I deal with that um I
think I internalized it when I was
younger and now I don't really care
here's the thing if someone is going to
make fun of you because you're a virgin
you don't want that person in your life
and also that person that joke says a
lot more about them than you that's a
lot easier said than done to you know
accept and move on from but who cares so
you're a virgin whatever world for
soccer I'm 29 and a virgin I see
attraction to both females and males but
I don't think I would have sex if given
the opportunity is that weird no that's
not weird because I read a lot of myself
in your question that honestly kind of
the only thing that's different is the
age I am attracted to men and women I
would like to have sex with men and have
sex with women and I had the opportunity
to and I didn't kind of take the person
up on it so is that weird no I don't
think it's weird I I did it
- I you're not alone I think
you just have to be comfortable and it's
fine if you want to wait and it's fine
if you're not comfortable and it doesn't
matter what age you are if you're not
comfortable if you're not comfortable
that's it if you're not feeling it
you're not feeling it
KDOT have you ever considered paying for
sex yeah I have cuz uh you know because
I've read romance novels there's been a
couple of romance novels where it's
involved a guy who's a gigolo and I'm
like wait and then I would fall in love
with him and all that crap but yes I've
considered it never done it I don't even
think I've looked it up but i-i've yeah
I've considered it for sure I mean you
can pay for almost anything right if I
don't cook and I seamless my dinner then
why wouldn't I just do it for this right
have you ever experimented with sex toys
only only recently and I think that
that's it's very personal and has to do
with like me and how I learned to touch
myself and but yeah I only recently I
will say now I feel like sex toys are a
little bit more accepted and maybe
people younger are using them like
younger than I've been being 32 and
getting your first vibrator which I hate
by the way so that'll be you know
something I have to explore but um yeah
I've experimented and I think and here's
the thing I had the privilege to go to a
really nice local shop in New York and
the salesperson who worked at the shop
was so nice and would listen and I
definitely was like circling a spiral
like on my leg like I was so nervous so
if you're looking for sex toys and you
have the opportunity to go to a shop the
people there are hopefully you have a
good experience because I did and and
they just want to help
Chris Joseph - did you have a do you
have advice for virgins who don't want
to lose their virginity but it's better
Priam pressured into it first of all I'm
sorry if you're being peer pressured
into it that sucks
I don't know why we put such I mean I
know why but there's so much emphasis on
virginity and then
maybe it's that people want you to be in
the group that they're in but my advice
would be to try your best to try your
best to remind yourself of what you want
not why you're doing it or not wire but
what do you want do you want to feel
comfortable great what does that mean
for you that means I don't have sex then
do that if what is comfortable is having
sex then have sex yeah any sort of
pressure try to remove yourself from it
and look at you and what do you want and
figuring out what you want can be really
hard I say that as a person who has
spent years trying to figure out what
they want and it takes a long time the
Celtic there the Celtic lady sorry
the Celtic lady have you ever been
rejected by a potential partner for
being a virgin and how did you deal with
that yes
so I was a drunk and hooking up with a
guy or like went to hook up with a guy
in college and I don't know how I said
it cuz I don't really remember but I
just remember we were hooking it we were
like making out a little bit and then we
didn't make out and then I woke up the
next day and we hadn't had sex and we we
just had like made out and then later on
at the bar like months later when he
sort of goes to me and whatever he had a
girlfriend and I kind of went up to him
and I asked like what's the deal like
what what happened and he was like well
you told me you you were a virgin and I
couldn't touch you at that point I
remember being like what and then I
remember because it was Halloween and he
kind of ruined it so then I went up to
because when you're drunk it's great to
get advice from strangers so I went up
to another person and was like hey if
you were drunk and you said this and
whatever and the guy was like oh nobody
wants to remember this he said nobody no
guy wants to sleep with a virgin which
is insane because statistically like
you're bound to but I I remember getting
really upset and like crying and then
being like I'm gonna do all the shots um
so yeah that was not a fun experience
and don't say that to people um Amy
Trainor are you scared to lose your
virginity I think what I'm scared
is getting close to someone I was I've
only so only the this summer the tail
end of my 31st year was I full-body
naked in front of someone you can tell
how naive I am that I still say like
full body naked cuz I think people just
normally say naked but yeah I so I'm at
a slower pace so I think I'm afraid for
someone to see me naked
if we're gonna go deeper for someone to
like see me right I'm like afraid of
like intimacy so if it's a little I the
moniker like virginity I'm not really
worried about that but there's other
there's other stuff attached that I'm
afraid of do you regret not losing your
virginity when you were younger uh no I
I don't regret not losing my virginity
when I was younger I am a little like I
kind of I reminisce about the time when
like just holding someone's hand was a
big deal when just kissing someone was a
big deal and it was a big deal and then
you you stopped you didn't have to rush
into anything
not that you have to rush into anything
at any age but our culture doesn't
really do a good job of letting things
be at a slower pace and just sort of
figuring it out so that's sort of what I
what I reminisce about but I don't
really have any regrets Broadway for
days how far have you gone sexually
romantically ah to the ends of the earth
no how far have I gone sexually or
romantically um
romantically I haven't gone that far I
have never had a boyfriend or a partner
sexually that's an interesting one so
sexually I would say we're gonna go by
basis sexually at second base third well
I don't really I forget what their faces
so let's not two bases
I've been felt up I've been here's the
thing
whenever I've hooked up with someone
it's never been great that they've like
wanted to will say digitally or orally
perform sex acts on me and I'm trying to
be as
as you know sort of cut and dry as
possible so they've been very bad at it
and it's like hurt so I'll move their
hand away and stuff so that's sad and so
not a lot has been done to me and then I
have performed oral sex on people that's
the extent of it
do you next question do you date not
really
I've dated kind of I don't love dating
apps I think it's great that people are
out there and I really really give props
to the people that do them because it is
it's daunting I love to download an app
for like a hot 72 hours and then delete
it because I get scared so no I don't
date I want to I think that I think it's
nice to meet people
yeah do you tell dates that you're a
virgin
um the few times that I've dated they've
either known cuz they know me or I might
tell them like date two but I don't
think it's something you have to come
out of the gate with or I think it's
something that you could come out of the
gate with it doesn't really I think as
long as you don't trot it out like as
long as you don't announce it like and
also like I'm ever as long as you don't
announce it like you have cancer cuz
it's not a bad thing right it's just
another part about you Andrew LaRose
asks as a 34 year old virgin I always
struggle with whether or not or whether
or not telling the person I want to get
close to yeah I can see how that would
be a struggle uh I think tell them tell
them and when you want to when it's
comfortable again I don't think for you
Andrew if you're like hi Andrew 34 year
old virgin LaRose nice to meet you I
don't think you need to do it like that
but especially I noticed just for me as
I get older I need things to be easier
so I need cards on the table I need
people to communicate a little bit
better so yeah eventually when I'm
comfortable with it I'm gonna I'm gonna
tell you because also if that person god
forbid is like a person who's gonna
judge you about your virginity
or get weird about it it's kind of it's
better to tell them upfront or a little
earlier in the front then when you're a
little more of an emotionally invested
yeah have you ever thought about selling
your virginity I have because there'll
be that story that cycles back a couple
you know every couple of years about
some person who's put it up online but I
don't think that I ever could I don't
think that I could ever go through with
it
yeah is it possible that maybe you're
gay or bi yes hello um I we I talked a
little bit about it but yeah I I grew up
very sexually repressed and very I kind
of unbeknownst to me it was taught to be
afraid and ashamed of like my body and
sex and sexuality and there was a little
bit of there was a little bit of
religion sprinkled on top of that so I
think that that doesn't lend itself to
really knowing who you are sexually but
I so I was never a person I love dirty
dancing the movie I didn't watch the
movie and think wow Jennifer Grey I
watched the movie and thought wow
Patrick Swayze but as I started to get
older and I realized certain things and
who I was attracted to and who I was
kind of meeting in my life I did realize
that there was sort of this bisexuality
that I didn't know what to do with and I
still sort of don't know what to do with
it I would love to date a woman I would
love to have sex with a woman I would
love to lose my virginity to a woman it
doesn't virginity is such an odd term
but yes
yes there's a possibility that I'm bi so
yeah
ruth gonzalez asks do you think that you
that if you lost your virginity you
would feel more confident with your body
that is such a good question i think i
used to think that cuz again when you
don't like yourself or when you have a
really low self-esteem you are gonna
look for evidence in the world to
support those beliefs so I used my
virginity as a way to support the fact
that I thought that I was a loser and
that my body's gross because no one will
have sex with me well that's not the
case and so as I struggle and try as
hard as I can to learn to love my body
more and as I struggle and learn I don't
really struggle with anymore but as I
learned to sort of accept that like
virginity is not really a big deal
the kind that it's it's a it shifted and
so I am a little more confident in my
body and so I don't think it's tied back
to virginity so that's a good question
how did you feel when you saw the film
40 year old virgin I loved it I love
Steve Carell I had the poster the the
movie poster on my wall in college you
know the college dorm room that it was
never seeing any action and and I have
like a little Steve Carell doll I
thought it was a really good way to
represent because that guy's a normal
guy right like I also think sometimes
people think virginity is like why they
don't look like when they go home and
it's like they look like me they look
like you they look like normal people
were normal it's just something that's
like you know kind of a construct kind
of thing you lose it if you lose it if
you don't like whatever it doesn't
really matter so I thought that they
portrayed him well and I thought that
the the female lead was really nice and
like accepting and I thought it was a
good a good example of that oh I'm gonna
butcher your name Sal ray you will how
asks how important is virginity to you I
think it used to be really important to
me and now it's not having said that
there is a tiny like a little nugget of
fear in the back that's like you know if
and when you start to really have sex
with people that's gonna it's gonna
probably be a lot of emotion for me
because for so long this is what I have
I've been but that's why I'm trying
really hard to not define myself with my
virginity because when that goes away
then I don't want to have some
existential like but Who am I you know
it's just another thing about me so I
would say that it was very important to
me and I am trying to make it kind of
the appropriate level of importance
which is like you know it's just
something about me is there any part of
you that feels like maybe you'll never
have sex sometimes come on if I want to
get really sad I'll be like yeah we're
gonna hope but yeah I don't really I
don't really think that anymore I'll say
maybe that in like a joking way but no I
think that and also like how are we
defining sex cuz I've done sex acts and
I've had some done to me so I've done
some things
uh but yeah I think if I want to go a
spiral and freak out which sometimes it
happens I'm human
that'll that'll come up Lewis I'm gay
and a virgin I'm 29 I'm scared to tell
my boyfriend because I think he'll be
disappointed and leave me uh Louise I
wish I could give you a hug is there a
way I can tell him I'm not ready yes and
you know what you wrote it right here
I'm not ready I know I know that this is
easier said than done but especially
when talking about stuff like this
sex and virginity and not being ready
and being comfortable it's best not to
mince words and I'm not ready is also
really well said because it's pretty
clear and also if he's your boyfriend
that means you guys have at least
committed to each other a little bit so
I'm hoping there's some understanding
and you know I'm sure that he likes you
and he wants you to be safe and
comfortable and happy and so if that
means that you're safe and comfortable
and happy not having sex with him then
you don't have to have sex there are
people who have full lives and don't
have sex for millions of reasons so I
think we're all gonna be okay it's just
trying to remember that and maybe if
there were better examples of you know
people out there who were living their
lives day in day out not having sex and
being fine do you want to have children
I do not want to have children I have
wonderful nieces and nephews and I think
that I was and I used to be a nanny and
I think I was put on this earth to be
sort of the aunt and nanny and I feel
like a child myself kind of so I need to
learn how to take care of myself
and also I'm really into plants right
now so I have a bunch of plant babies
that I'm very excited about McKenzie
Spangler writes do you feel that
virginity is a concept or a definite or
a different yeah I think virginity's a
concept I think it's a construct I think
it's all of those like it's just it's
it's what did it used to be rightly tied
to Adele read to a piece of land it's
like used for purity some tie it's crap
that's what it is I think it's I think
it's crap I think it's one more way
we put by the way we put a lot of
virginity as a heteronormative thing and
as a thing on women like straight women
and it we don't focus on the guys we
focus a little bit on the guys we cut a
whole bunch of people off in the LGBTQIA
community so yeah I think it's crap I
think it's a crap concept and I think we
all need to sort of open our minds about
it and we'll all be better relaxed
Emily's videos rights do you have any
advice to an 18 year old virgin should I
worry about it or just let it be Emily
great question uh let it be like the
Beatles yeah I wouldn't worry about it
only because um I spent so much talking
about regrets do I regret not losing my
virginity No do I regret worrying about
it oh my god yes the amount of time that
I spent worrying about losing my
virginity I could have gotten my masters
written a screenplay learned a new sport
learn a new language gone to Europe
backpacked gone and other masters got a
PhD had all the plant babies in the
world yeah don't spend your time
worrying I know that so much easier said
than done but if you can find a way to
stop worrying about it and do literally
anything else it will just be so much
better for you take that from someone
who wasted a lot of time
SILS six pants DIY what do you think sex
feels like mmm well here's what I'll say
virgins and non-virgins there's a thing
that happens when you say that you're a
virgin specifically I'm talking about my
experience with straight women who were
like oh my god the first time sucks and
you're like okay thank you so much for
that unsolicited advice story that you
just told me so unfortunately I kind of
now I'm like I think the first time
might suck but hopefully sex feels good
what do I think sex feels like like
bodies rubbing together and hopefully
you're both like enjoying it I think
it's a lot more athletic than
we'll let on yeah
obscured whitey have you ever had an
orgasm pretty sure I have yeah pretty
sure but um there was years when I was
trying to figure out you know how to
touch myself and what I liked that I was
like I don't think that this is it also
should it take this long hmm so yeah and
I think it I think it changes too and
depending on who you are it also like
you don't have to try to achieve an
orgasm like in your bed on your back
like there are you can there's a bunch
of different ways that you can try to
get to that um but also like orgasms are
nice and they're important but also
talking about putting pressure on
yourself like that's another thing that
we can do to like put a lot of pressure
on ourselves so I've obviously haven't
had sex but I've heard from people who
have sex that say like orgasm isn't the
end-all be-all and when I was a sort of
naive unaware judgmental virgin like
when I was in college and there would be
girls who had stories about having sex
with guys and they didn't have an orgasm
might be like oh my god then what's the
point and they would just look at me
like she doesn't get it so yeah maybe
focus on that less or more I don't know
you want to feel good
um toby flenderson I love that name I
feel like I'm ashamed of my body and I'm
scared to be seen nude how do you have
so much confidence Toby I don't it might
look like I do a red lipstick helps Toby
I suggest you try I don't have a lot of
confidence I was full body full body
naked nude in front of someone for the
first time in front of a member of the
opposite sex in like a sexual way for
the first time this summer at the lovely
age of 31 and I got out of the bathroom
of this guy's apartment and I was
walking towards him and I actively
thought well he's seen me naked laying
down but my body looks different when
you stand up and so I was a little tipsy
but I took my hands and I kind of did
like a dance move to try to minimize
what he would see I don't know how to be
confident
or comfortable I'm trying what helps me
is following people on social media that
are confident and comfortable in their
body so for me Liz oh and Nicole Byer
are wonderful women that are so
confident that I just I I look at them
sometimes to to get inspiration
Christina writes does not having sex
make your relationships simpler or
difficult well if I had relationships
this would be important no I am it can
it it can sometimes be more difficult so
like I've tried the dating apps but I
think the reason I delete them is like
what am I gonna do I'm gonna do a little
banter meet you for a drink and then if
you're trying to go home and have sex I
have to be like no I'm good and then I
have to kind I have to like you enough
to like see you again for a couple more
dates feel comfortable that I'm telling
you you're that I'm a virgin hope that
you don't judge me so yeah I I guess it
makes it more difficult or maybe that's
me making it difficult and I should just
go in guns blazing what's up I'm a 32
year old virgin do you want the whiskey
or the vodka like let's just put it all
out there so I don't know cartwheel 2002
why do people put so much importance on
virginity in your opinion well we love
to divide ourselves right we love like
an us-versus-them so I think that's part
of it and maybe because it is while I'm
saying like it's not that important
virginity as a construct I don't think
is that important sex is important and
when you're having sex when you're young
or the first time you're having sex the
first time you're doing anything I think
that's important so I think that I think
that maybe the water got a little muddy
right so I think that it's I don't I
don't think you should be like blase
about having sex for the first time or
when you're young or when you're trying
to experiment that I think you should
take seriously
I think virginity as a as a
heteronormative construct is kind of the
throw away so maybe that's it that it
got a little wires crossed
because sex is a big deal so I think
that that that should be taken seriously
the one with a B writes how have the
people around you reacted when they
learn that you're a virgin
they're usually shocked because I mostly
like I curse like a truck driver and I
don't hold back from talking about
things so I think that they assume that
I've had sex but I don't lie about it I
know I won't be in a conversation and it
never really happens like this but I
wouldn't if someone were like well you
know when you're having sex I wouldn't
be like nope I mean I wouldn't I
wouldn't lie wouldn't be like yeah no I
get it I would I don't know if I would
offer up and be like no I'm a virgin it
would depend on the group and if I just
met them or how comfortable I feel but
yet people are people are a little a
little shocked but then it's mostly like
oh cool so anyway this one time I mean
you know that's sort of a good test
right so not that you should be throwing
it out there like a test but definitely
be mindful of people's reactions and if
they judge you or they treat you
differently or you know whatever it's
time to cut them out of your life I mean
I I think because what the hell how do
you feel about the word virgin I think
it's kind of crap I think the word is
crap because I think it ties to
heteronormative I think it ties to like
being pure which what what does that
mean you know like we're all pure we're
all fine
yeah being good being so I don't like
the word and I think that also that's
what helped me when I was trying to
figure out how I felt about my virginity
and as I got older because you just sort
of realize things as you get older that
like don't matter like I don't I don't
care and it's a silly word gazpacho
great soup because spa cho soup um have
you ever been in love no but I will say
that there is a man in my life who
pretty much three times a week tells me
that he loves me and I believe that he's
sincere and he is a delivery man for a
company that I work at and it's nice but
now I've never I've never been in love
Jill schniperson scuzz they have
great food if so grab me a burger Jill
snipper if you had a time machine would
you go back to your teen years to lose
your virginity no Jill if I had a time
machine first of all don't make me go
back to being a teenager you could pay
me a million dollars I'd be like hard
pass the teenagers are so hard and I it
wouldn't no I would not go back and lose
my virginity there was not a person I
wanted to lose it to I was more than
happy being busy worrying about grades
and getting into college and having
anxiety no I would not in a million
years absolutely not um but good
question Jill god if I an advice I find
a time machine
why would I go back to being a teenager
never I would want to go anywhere else
but that lovely and untitled - asks your
oh gee they just say you're a unicorn
well thank you that's so nice
aren't we all
but yeah I mean if you meant like Wow
rare a 32 year old virgin there's a lot
of us out there that for a case in point
the 34 year old guy who wrote in
Katherine McCallum writes what do you do
in conversations about sex and
relationships with friends I'm always
just awkwardly hovering not really being
able to contribute to the conversation
hahaha I've been there so yeah
definitely if you're getting down to
like the nitty-gritty turn in terms of
like advice I'm not gonna step in and be
like well what I've heard because I
don't have any leg to stand on but so
unless it's like nitty-gritty about sex
advice what I found that happens with my
friends and I is that when we're talking
about sex and relationships it really
comes down to you know connections or
communications or really personal things
that any one of us have experienced and
and have a lot less to do with sex than
you would think but also I'm a very
curious virgin so like I like to act
like a little journalist and I'm like
tell me more like and then what happened
and then so I like to analyze and I love
everybody's sex stories tell me all the
sex stories I want to hear them and now
yeah standing around awkwardly so I
would maybe say you know try to embrace
that
what you bring to the conversation and
what you don't bring and that it's okay
and hopefully if they're if they're your
friends they might notice that you're
standing around silently I mean like oh
hey we you know how you feel and bring
you into it a little bit more is there a
difference between being a virgin and
someone who just doesn't want to have
sex that's a good question um is there a
difference between being a virgin and
someone who just doesn't want to have
sex well I mean so then is it implied
that a virgin does when I have sex or
doesn't right that's why that word is so
stupid
but from society standpoint not my
opinion but from society yes I think
that those would be constituted as
different cuz I think society thinks
virgin is someone who's like hoping and
praying and waiting and wishing that
they'll lose it cuz that's another thing
too like I'm cool I'm good like it'll
happen
but I'm not like you know turn into
every stranger being like please put
your body on my body and then so someone
who just doesn't to have sex there are
people who don't want to have sex for a
bunch of different reasons and they
don't all have me up mine are very
specific other people's can be for a
number of different reasons so yeah it's
fine to not want to have sex
Christian Laurie Ola why do people put
pineapple on pizza I don't know but have
you ever tried it I'm gonna stop you
right there because I used to ask this
question to people who put pineapple on
it and then you know what I did I got
myself a bruised ute and pineapple pizza
and oh baby you gotta try it it's really
good but I love sugar too so I think
also maybe people do it because it's
like a sweet and a savory together great
question great non sex question I'm here
to answer all your Pizza questions as
well do you think the word virgin is
like fetishized
is a fetish I do yeah cuz I think it
goes back to like the idea of purity and
and it's typically like I mean depending
on who you are kind of close your eyes
and think about what a virgin is and
then and then think about what comes
into your head cuz is it like a young
girl who's like I'm just like really
eNOS
whole is that whole thing is crap and
yes that's fetishized that's like the
infantilizing of women and yes and again
cutting off all the LGBTQ people when we
do that so yeah I do think it's
fetishized William Forest Hill are you a
senator that's a great name
I would vote for you depending on your
beliefs William Forest Hill writes did
anxiety contribute to your virginity I'm
extremely anxious how do you overcome it
in relationships yes William it did it
did very much contribute to my virginity
I was really anxious to have sex and
really nervous to even think about sex
even thinking about hooking up how did
you overcome overcome it for
relationships well I don't really date
and I don't really get into
relationships so I don't think that I
have like a you know tied up in a
perfect bow answer for that because I
would say if I'm being honest that I'm
still extremely anxious and my anxiety
drives a lot of relationships like I'm
not out there dating I don't put myself
out there because I'm scared and it's
exhausting and it's a lot easier to go
home and not do anything but that also
means that you're like cutting yourself
off from living not the dating is
awesome but it's you know part of life
so yeah of anxiety drives a lot of what
I do and so that sucks and it's
something I'm working on tako styles
rights is your first kiss something you
should keep like your virginity um no
well okay so there's a lot to be said
for the way you phrase your question
right so it's something you should keep
like your virginity so I'm assuming that
because of the way you phrased it that
you believe you should keep your
virginity so and that's totally we you
can think that in terms of okay so if
we're thinking keep your virginity maybe
for like marriage do you think you
should keep your first kiss for no I
would kiss someone that you want to that
you like that has consented that it
wasn't that you're both having fun and
you like
each other and you care about each other
yeah I think my first kiss was in
seventh grade and we both had braces and
it was in this guy's like little
brother's room the little brother wasn't
in there but it was like on a half day
it was really weird but fun and awkward
so yeah kiss when you want to kiss when
you feel comfortable that's what should
matter but in terms of keeping it I
don't think so
I think maybe go out there and get a
little bit of kissing experience and in
terms of kissing like you're not gonna
get pregnant you're not gonna get an STD
so like yeah smooch it up live it asks
oh just says you're awesome the fact
that you can talk openly about this is
really inspiring
well thanks live it yeah I don't really
I guess there was a point in time I
maybe over time that I just stopped
trying to have it to find me so much and
it's part of who I mean it's it's a part
of my story right so people ask
questions like well why didn't you have
sex in your 20s and so yeah I talked
about it why not
yellow swaggins uh-huh have you ever
used tinder yes
Oh tinder tinder is tinder is is kind of
like the Internet and that it can be a
wonderful treasure or a horrible
nightmare and I'll just say this the
last person I talked to on tinder asked
me uh nayana Klee if I could poop on
their face so it's tough out there guys
right but I'll also say too that if
you're watching and that's your fetish
I'm not trying to poop shame you there's
a time and a place and there's people
and they do it and that's fine but like
that's what you're getting on tinder
like that and that wasn't like we were
talking for days that was like he said
it right at the top but part of me is
like I'm kind of making fun of you but
part of me is like if that's your fetish
maybe you do need to say it at the top
right cuz like that's a pretty big make
or break but yeah I've been
and I love to download it play around
and then delete it but I appreciate the
people that are sticking it out on there
and people have met on there and and
it's great for some people I don't know
I've never listed my virginity on there
like I think I would get maybe I should
do that as an experiment I should go and
like put that in my profile because I
think their responses would be insane uh
yes virginity is a heteronormative term
and it's kind of silly right so what
does that even mean because the second
question is would you prefer to lose
your virginity someone who's also a
virgin well what does that mean have
they done nothing have they just not had
you know straight person sex and what
does that look like um I used to think I
wanted to lose my virginity to someone
who was also a virgin and now I kind of
here's I think about it you know when
you really put on a bunch of layers for
winter and you have mittens and all this
stuff and so sometimes you need even
isn't you're an adult you need someone
to like help you unzip your coat and
take your stuff off and then because
they've kind of taken off their mittens
and stuff like that so sometimes I think
about having set at two virgins having
sex is like just two people who have
just come in from skiing and they have
all the mittens and the scarves on and
like they could just agree we can't get
at anything but that's silly
there's also something sweet to be said
for somebody who's kind of on your level
and like you they haven't experienced it
and you haven't experienced it I don't
really it doesn't really matter to me
how can I sit here is someone who's like
I don't think virginity is a big deal
and then be like oh but I don't want to
sleep with I've heard you like so no I
don't really care let's explore together
what is your what is your advice to
teenagers who still have their virginity
I think it's I hesitate to give you
advice because I want to initially just
ask how you feel because if some of
those teenagers feel comfortable then my
advice is great keep feeling comfortable
see ya later and if some of you are
uncomfortable and want to have sex then
my advice is be safe make sure that you
are with someone who respects you and go
ahead and try it so it's tough in terms
of what I think you might mean is like
advice for teenagers who still have
their virginity because of like societal
pressures and also I didn't grow up in
high school with Instagram or Facebook I
cannot imagine what you people what what
teenagers have to deal with nowadays I
cannot imagine the instagrams and
Facebook's and all the stuff and I just
I feel like I want to be like I'm so
sorry even if I didn't make them so as
best you can try to remember that it is
so easy to put stuff online that's fake
and it is really hard or just that we
don't do it we don't put stuff online
that's like the real story so just try
not to compare you know it's hard
Mariella writes did your parents discuss
sex with you while you were growing up
my mom did my dad didn't at all because
it was kind of like my my parents
unknowingly because their little old
school kind of split the the house and
it was like my mom will raise the kids
and my dad will just do his job so it
was kind of delegated as such that my
mom would talk about sex which was tough
because she was like religious and she's
had her own experiences which were not
all positive so that there's a lot of
stuff they can get passed down on
knowingly and and sort of infiltrate
into a belief system and you're a kid
and you don't even know and then it
happened you know and I was in my 20s
and I had to really parse out like what
do I believe about sex and is it my
belief or is it someone else's and where
did that come from so that can be really
tough sometimes with parents and sex so
it's it's tough all right
um this is the last question this has
been so much fun thank you so much for
being here blah is the name thank you
for being comfortable enough to speak to
us you know what blog thank you for
being here but yeah I I wasn't always
this comfortable to talk about virginity
but I'm really happy that I got to this
place and it took a lot of like self
work and just just like more years of
being a virgin and realizing that you'll
meet a bunch of people from a bunch of
different walks of life a bunch of
different sexualities and virginity will
not be the most important or interesting
thing about them or you thank you so
much again for asking your questions I
really appreciate it and I had so much
fun
subscribe to BuzzFeed video I'm not
going to tell you where to click because
you guys are Millennials and you all
know so subscribe and thank you so much
again